Deco I'll beat this guy
even if it costs my life
mar 7
dare
[music] yeah yeah yeah [music] [music] It's a
fluke What is that?
It's said that the resentment of food is terrifying.The
one shot just now,
the resentment of being able to eat the last bite of the
move.I don't know,
it's so close that my body changes.
I can't forgive the fact that I'm making a fool of myself with the village, but I
'm going
to have a
hard time with my boss.
I'm going to be overworked I'm just saying I'm the
one who made you look like a burger health udon It's
better than having the last bite of any breathing dish stolen It's better than being ridiculed by the
web I
can't forgive you
ana
Wake up and it'll stick, but it's a
good
day oh
rar